معنا من جباليا الصحفي عماد زقوط عماد
قربنا من الوضع هناك في
جباليا نعم ما زالت الاليات العسكريه
متواجده في منطقه جباليه البلد تحديدا في
وسط ى الشرق من جبال البلاد ما زالت هذه
الاليات العسكريه هي متواجده هنالك حركه
للمواطنين من مخيم جباليا الى مناطق
جباليه الجهه الغربيه تحديدا من يريد
التوجه الى منطقه ابو اسكندر في الشيخ
رضوان و ايضا كذلك الى منطقه جباليه
النزله الا ان الاليات ما زالت هي متواجده
في وسط
وا الجهه الشرقيه ل جباليا البلد كذلك حسب
هنالك مصادر طبيه وكذلك شود عيان
والمتابعه الميدانيه ان الطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه زادت ورفعت من وثيره
استهدافات للمواطنين الفلسطينيين فقد
استشهد خلال الساعات الاخيره تسعه مواطنين
جراء استهدافات من الطائرات المسيره العس
العسكريه الاسرائيليه هنالك ثلاثه مواطنين
تم استهدافهم واستشهادهم على الفور في
منطقه تل الزعتر وكذلك مواطنين اثنين في
منطقه زمو شرق جباليا وايضا هنالك مواطنين
اثنين في منطقه بئر النعجه في غرب جباليا
هؤلاء المواطنين تسعه الذين تم استشهادهم
خلال الساعات الاخيره جراء الاستهدافات من
الطائرات المسيره العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وايضا كذلك حسب تبعات بعد الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من مدينه بيت حنون وجدنا عدد
كبير من الشهداء في هذه المنطقه وتحديدا
في مدخل بيت حنون وقد تحللت اجسادهم بشكل
كامل في هذه المناطق وايضا هنالك حسب
مصادر صحفيه وشهود عيان ان الكلاب الضال
ايضا كما نهشت هذه هذه الجثث جثث الشهداء
بعد ان تم القائها في الشوارع والساحات
العامه لايام طويله جراء تواجد الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في تلك المناطق كذلك
هنالك تحركات عسكريه اسرائيليه في الجهه
الشرقيه الجنوبيه ل جباليا ربما باتجاه
منطقه مدينه غزه تحديدا حي الدرج والتفاح
هذه ال كذلك المدفعيه الاسرائيليه الليله
الماضيه استهدفت منطقه بركه ابو راشد وسط
مخيم جباليه بعده قذائف مدفعيه اصابت تلك
المنطقه بعدد من القذائف خلال الساعات
الاخيره وفجر اليوم من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه على كل الاحوال المسيرات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه ما زالت تحلق بشكل
منخفض في اجواء شمال قطع غزه تحديدا في
مناطق مخيم جباليا وجباليا وجباليا النزله
حيث التحركات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في تلك
المناطق الانسحابات الاسرائيليه عاده
تموضع لتلك الاليات العسكريه في المناطق
الشرقيه تحديدا لجبال ووسط
باليا تطورات في هذه المنطقه ايضا بعد
الانسحابات من الجهه الغربيه
للجبال بعد قليل ل متابعه الامر حسب شهود
العيان من وصل من الاهالي الى مخيم جبال
يتحدث عن حاله من الدمار وحاله من الخراب
في هذه المناطق التي كانت تتواجد فيها
اليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه يعني تحدثت عن
العثور على جثث كثيره في الشوار بدات
تتحلل وتنهشه الكلاب هل هي لاشخاص
لفلسطينيين تم استهدافهم بالاعدادات
الميدانيه بكل تاكيد في منطقه بيت حنين
هناك بيت حنون هنالك جثث شهداء قد تحللت
بشكل كامل اصبحت عباره عن هياكل عظميه في
هذه المنطقه في مدينه بيت حنون تحديدا على
مدخل مدينه بيت حنون ومنطقه عزبه بيت حنون
وسط مدينه بيت حنون هنالك عشرات الشهداء
وجدوا في هذه المناطق وقد اعدموا وقد
اصيبوا ايضا بالغارات الاسرائيليه
المتواصله على تلك المنطقه وجدنا حاله
صعبه ل لجثث الشهداء وقد تحللت بشكل كامل
اصبحت عباره عن هيكل عظمي اي في هذه
المناطق التي كانت تتواجد فيها هذه الجثث
على مدار الايام الاخيره ربما الاسابيع
الاخيره وربما ايضا منذ بدء العمليه
البريه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مدينه بيت
حنون اذا هناك في كل منطقه تنسحب منها هذه
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه نجد عشرات
الشهداء ملقون على الارض في هذه المناطق
كما كما حدث في منطقه الاندونيسي وتل الزع
الشيخ زايد ومشروع بيت لاهيه وكذلك في
مستشفى العدوان وايضا في مناطق من جبال
البلد والمناطق الغربيه من مخيم جباليا
ومن جبالي البلد هذه المناطق التي تنسحب
منها الاليات العسكريه وبعد ان نذهب الى
تلك المناطق نجد عشرات الشهداء وقد تتحل
تحللت هذه ال الجثث ولكن في منطقه بيت
حنون وقد تحللت بشكل كامل واصبحت عباره عن
هيكل عظمي ملقى على الارض في هذه المناطق
في مدينه بيت حنون شمال قطاع غزه شكرا لك
عماد زقوت الصحفي الفلسطيني كنت معنا من
جباليه